-The president held his first
rally in months on Saturday
in an attempt to project
political strength
as his administration faces
a series of crises.
Instead, it was a flop,
and I should say
I get that he wanted to go out
and see people.
I've been in an attic
for three months.
I miss having guests.
Zoom is great.
It's not face to face.
But I deal with it because there
isn't a better option.
It's not like there's a magic
door behind me
that'll send me a guest if I say
their name three times.
Ethan Hawke! Ethan Hawke!
Ethan Hawke!
Right?
I mean, that would be stupid,
but also, I mean,
I mean, how cool would that be?
With that said, you know,
I haven't totally hated
the "me" time.
It's definitely allowed me
to get in touch with myself
in a healthy way, and, you know,
if a guest was here
they'd probably want to
go on and on about
whatever project they had,
and, you know,
I don't -- I don't need that.
Still, I don't think that would
be the case with Ethan Hawke.
I mean, the Ethan Hawke.
Does go on a bit.
But he's Ethan Hawke! He's one
of my all-time favorite actors.
Love me some Ethan Hawke.
Of course, knowing Ethan,
he'd probably have some sort
of psychopath man-in-the-woods
beard right now
and wouldn't be
that camera-ready.
Yeah, all things --
all things considered,
it's good not having Ethan Hawke
right now.
Anyway, I know it was
a long time ago,
and I probably shouldn't
even say this.
I thought in "Dead Poets"
when he stood on the desk
and said, "O Captain!
My Captain!"
it was just a little,
I don't know, showoff-y?
-It was a character!
-Anyway,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
In this moment, protesters
across the country
are demanding an end
to institutional racism
and police brutality,
the coronavirus pandemic is
spiking in more than 20 states,
our election infrastructure
is falling apart,
and millions of Americans
are camping out for hours
just to file for unemployment
amid a historic economic crisis.
I mean, look at this.
This is insane.
Normally, you only see people
camped out on the sidewalk
like this when there's
a new iPhone
or Harry Styles is hosting
"SNL,"
an episode, by the way,
that I couldn't get tickets to,
which is crazy because I had
a bit of a run there.
This is truly, truly barbaric.
If you're a billion-dollar
corporation,
you can just call up
the government,
you get a loan
you don't even need.
But if you lose your job
thanks to a pandemic
the government failed to stop,
you have to line up in the heat
for hours like you're waiting
for a porta-potty at Ozzfest.
And as Ozzy himself would say,
our country is
♪ Going off the rails
on a crazy train ♪
Yes.
Anyway, I just hope
it's not too late
to learn how to love
and forget how to hate.
That was for older brothers
born between, what, '63 and '71?
The point is we're in a moment
of acute national crisis,
thanks in large part
to the maligned negligence
of this taxidermied
business husk.
Wow! How'd the sales trip go,
Willy Loman?
I hope Biff didn't wander in
on you and a strange woman.
That would send him
in a long tailspin.
What happened to you?
You look like you just coached
the Knicks to a 50-point loss.
You should be standing
next to Jack Lemmon
begging for
the Glenn Gary leads.
We should never
have to see the president
in such a pathetic state.
It's embarrassing.
The president is supposed to
project confidence and strength.
Trump, on the other hand,
looks like a drunk wedding guest
shuffling back to the Marriott.
[ As Trump ] Or was it a Hyatt.
[ Normal voice ] This is
like when you stay up
past your bedtime and catch
a glimpse of your dad
coming home late from work
totally plastered.
Somehow,
this is the perfect imagine
to sum up the Trump presidency.
Now we just have to change
the presidential seal
to a drunk eagle snoozing
in a BarcaLounger
with a beer in one hand
and remote control in the other.
And I know. I know eagle's hands
are called claws.
I made a mistake.
But it's tempting --
Or maybe they're called talons.
Well, I should have
looked this up.
But as tempting as it may be
to think that Trump
somehow created all the problems
our country is facing,
he did not.
He certainly made them worse,
and in many cases,
profited from them.
But the structural inequities
and institutional failures
we're seeing right now
long predated him.
They were created in part
by guys like Johnny Bolton
over here, the ex-National
Security Advisor
who refused to testify
at Trump's impeachment
and is now hawking a book
called "Mustache Rides Again."
Oh, wait, I think it's called
"The Trash Behind the Stache."
No, wait, you know what, guys?
I think it's called
"Boltin' Bolton's Butt Ton
of Bull Dung."
Anyway, you can find it
on Amazon
under the "Please Light Your
Money on Fire Instead" section.
John Bolton is an unrepentant
warmonger who has helped
usher in some
of the worst calamities
of the last two decades and who
epitomizes our era of venal,
self-serving sociopaths
burning everything down
and then cashing in
as they slink away.
But other than that,
he a great guy.
Last night, Bolton was on ABC
trying to sell his book
about his time
in the Trump White House.
Trump, a man, let's not forget,
he voted for and then lobbied
to get a job with.
-I don't think he's fit
for office.
I don't think he has the
competence to carry out the job.
-You supported Donald Trump
during the 2016 election.
You watched his first 15 months
in office.
What did you think of the job
he was doing up to that point?
-I think I made a mistake.
-No, I don't think he did.
I don't think he made a mistake.
I think you're a remora,
you know those little fish
that swim alongside sharks
and eat whatever they miss?
That's what all these
Trump White House
supporting cast members are.
And then,
when their bellies are full,
they swim out of the White House
and write a book called,
"Damn, That Shark Was Crazy!"
"I think a made a mistake"
is not how you talk about
enthusiastically supporting
and working for
a racist authoritarian
who's trampling our democracy
for his own self-interest.
That's what you say when you get
the Domino's order and realize
it has peppers
instead of pepperoni.
"Oh, damn it.
I think I made a mistake.
I meant to get pizza, but
instead I ordered Domino's."
Bolton didn't make a mistake.
He saw Trump in 2016
and throughout the first half
of his presidency
promising to rip up
the Iran deal
and to kill the families
of terrorists
and banning of Muslims,
and he thought he could use
Trump to get what he wanted.
It only backfired
when he realized Trump's like
a tiger in a circus act.
He starts out friendly,
but one wrong move,
and he will lunge for your face.
People like Bolton are
a big part of the reason
we're in this mess in the first
place, and on top of that,
the structural inequities
in our sham democracy
ensure that a party with
a disastrous 20-year record
of governance over the course
of two historically
awful presidents
can keep winning elections.
They don't need to be popular
if voter suppression
and an antiquated
electoral college system
can keep them in power.
And sure enough, the Trump team
is already sending signals
that they plan to interfere
with the actual administration
of the election.
This weekend, for example,
the Attorney General Bill Barr
repeated a series of obvious
lies about mail-in voting,
which many state officials,
including Republicans,
have turned to as a safe
alternative during the pandemic.
Barr claimed falsely
that mail-in ballots
somehow open the floodgates
to fraud.
-Well, there's a big discussion
right now about mail-in voting.
Hillary Clinton said it's fine,
it's fair.
-Well, it absolutely opens
the floodgates to fraud.
Those things
are delivered into mailboxes.
They can be taken out.
There's questions about
whether or not it even denies
a secret ballot because a lot
of the states have you signing
the outside of the envelope,
so the person
who opens the envelope
will know how people voted.
There's no -- Right now,
a foreign country could print up
tens of thousands
of counterfeit ballots
and it'd be very hard for us
to detect which was the right
and which was the wrong ballot.
So I think it can --
it can upset and undercut
the confidence
in the integrity
of our elections.
-You know what upsets confidence
in the integrity
of our elections?
People having to stand in line
to vote like they're waiting
to take pictures with the mall
Santa on December 23rd.
Of course,
if Bill Barr was in charge,
they'd have to line up
on August 8th.
Second,
none of what you said is true.
You can't just print up fake
mail ballots and send them in.
You know they still check
to make sure
they're from registered voters,
right?
It's not like you could just
write on a piece of paper
"I vote for Joe Exotic" and send
it to the Board of Elections,
although honestly, at this rate,
I'm desperate enough to try it.
Hey!
I think he's learned his lesson.
I saw some real growth from Joe.
And then this morning,
Trump himself tweeted...
They're trying to cheat
by disrupting
the actual administration
of the election,
and that's because they're
so worried that if voters
get to vote fairly,
he won't win.
Donald Trump is now
and has always been
a historically unpopular
president.
He's just been able to mask
his unpopularity
and soothe his ego
with large crowds
at his mosh pit/group therapy
sessions,
which is why his rally
in Tulsa on Saturday,
his first in months,
was planned as a big show
of political strength, nevermind
the fact that Tulsa
is a coronavirus hotspot
with spiking numbers
that have alarmed
local health officials.
Trump disregarded that just
to make himself feel better.
Beforehand, Trump base told CNN
that the rally wasn't
just about politics.
It was...
You know what else
is good for that? Prozac.
You just slip some
into his hamburger,
you know, the way you
give pills to a dog.
Or slap a label on the bottle
that says, "Hydroxychloroquine."
[ As Trump ]
This stuff cures neverything.
[ Normal voice ]
Think about that --
The president held an indoor
rally at a coronavirus hotspot,
putting people's lives at risk
just to make himself
feel better.
Can't we just get that truck
back to the White House lawn
and let him honk the horn
a few times?
"Do you feel better,
Mr. President?"
[ As Trump ] I am feeling
a little bit better.
[ Normal voice ] At this rate,
he should be doing his rallies
on a fainting couch
while a doctor takes notes.
Still, there you go --
The president's aides
said Saturday's rally would
put him in a much better mood,
and clearly,
Trump was looking forward to it
because he spent all week
bragging
about the number of people
who had RSVP'd.
-They have a new, a pretty new,
magnificent arena,
as you probably have heard.
And we're getting
exact numbers out,
but we're either close
to or over one million people
wanting to go.
We have a 22,000-seat arena,
but I think we're gonna
also take the convention hall
next door,
and that's gonna hold 40,000.
So we'll have 22,000,
plus 40,000,
which would mean that we'd
have over 900,000 people
that won't be able to go, but
hopefully they'll be watching.
But it's an amazing -- Nobody's
ever heard of numbers like this.
-You got to love how Trump
thinks a success is a situation
in which 90% of his supporters
get screwed.
[ As Trump ] Also,
we have a baked potato bar,
all the fixings for everyone
who doesn't get in.
Just the two potatoes, though,
so show up early.
[ Normal voice ] Nobody's ever
heard numbers like this?
You know what number of people
have heard?
6,200, the actual number
of people who showed up,
according to the fire marshall,
and that fire marshall
was probably the only person in
Tulsa who had a good night.
He was like, "Oh, this is great.
If there's a fire,
we'll get everybody out of here
in, like, 30 seconds."
Trump's team kept ramping up
expectations.
His campaign manager
Brad Parscale bragged
that a million people --
a million people had RSVP'd
and that they'd have a total
of close to 100,000.
You guys sure you want to
call your shot like that?
You're like a basketball player
giving
a pre-game press conference
about how many points he scored.
"You know, I just want
to thank God
and my teammates
for supporting me.
It wasn't easy to score a 50
in a game, but I did it.
All right. I'm gonna go warm up.
Achilles is pretty tight."
Although my favorite,
favorite Trump prediction
has to be this one.
-And we expect to have --
you know,
it's like
a record-setting crowd.
We've never had an empty seat.
And we certainly won't
in Oklahoma.
-We certainly won't have
an empty seat in Oklahoma.
It's too perfect.
This is like if Babe Ruth
had pointed to center field
and then stepped into the box
and fouled one off his ankle.
"Oh [bleep]!
Oh, no, I think I broke it!
Oh [bleep]!
Can you edit out the part
where I pointed?
We're live?! Oh [bleep]!"
So the president banked
not only his political comeback
but his mood in a big show
of force in Tulsa.
And then, you know,
this happened.
-President Trump's
first campaign rally
in more than 100 days
drew controversy
and a smaller-than-expected
crowd.
The upper decks of the arena
there in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
were largely empty.
-There were plenty of empty
seats
in the 19,000-capacity BOK
Center.
-But in the end, the president
was a bit of a bust in Tulsa.
Campaign quickly dismantling
one venue.
That other venue,
about one-third full.
Tulsa's fire department
saying about 6,200 people
showed up in an arena that held
19,000 for the president.
Wow, I've seen less empty seats
at an improv show.
And, let's be honest,
Trump's rallies are basically
an improv show where he gives
himself his own suggestion.
[ As Trump ] Can I have the name
of a famous person?
I heard Hillary.
[ Normal voice ] The arena
wasn't even one-third full.
Trump staked his political
fortunes and his ego
on this rally, and it was such
a flop,
they even had to cancel
a planned second speech
to what they thought would be
an overflow crowd outside.
Before Trump had landed,
crews were literally
breaking down the stage because
so few people were there.
Wow! He's the President
of the United States,
and they're treating him
like the least popular band
at Coachella.
"Sorry, bro, I guess everybody
went over to see Beyoncé.
You can keep the lanyards
if you want.
What kind of music do you guys
do anyway? Rage rap?"
And Trump's performance was just
as lackluster as the attendance.
You'd think at a moment like
this, the president might
want to offer soothing words
about the state of the nation
and the various crises we face.
Instead, Trump spent one
of every eight minutes in Tulsa
complaining about coverage
of his West Point speech.
Specifically, he complained
about the coverage
of the way he tiptoed
down a ramp
like a toddler on ice skates,
and the way he drank water.
-So then my wife said,
"Well, it wasn't only the ramp.
Did you have water?"
So what happens is I said, "What
does it have to do with water?"
They said,
"You couldn't lift your hand up
to your mouth with water."
She said,
"Well, I know what you did.
You had on a very good red tie."
And I don't want to get water
on the tie.
And I don't want to drink much.
So I lifted up the water.
I see we have a little glass
of water.
Where the hell did this water
come from?
[ Cheers and applause ]
So I put it up to my lip,
and then I say, because
I don't want it -- Just in case.
And they gave me
another disease.
[ Laughter ]
They gave me another disease.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Seriously, has a president's
base ever set a lower bar?
"Whoo! That arm works!
That arm works!"
The crowd cheered the president
drinking water with one hand
the way NASA cheered when
they landed a rover on Mars.
That's not supposed
to be impressive.
"Good news, he's drinking water
with one hand" is something
a doctor would say to you about
a loved one who was recently
hit on the head by a falling can
of paint.
"He's regained motor function
in his right arm.
Unfortunately, he is, um...
he is still having trouble
with the ramp."
Although the biggest lie
in that story might be the idea
that he had a conversation
with his wife.
And even if he did, what
a horrible conversation.
Her first question to you
was, "Did you have water?"
That's not a question you ask
a president or a loved one.
That's a question you ask
a sick cat.
The president staked
his political fortunes
on a rally
that turned out to be a dud
amid a series of mounting crises
that have deflated
his already historically bad
poll numbers.
It's a reminder that this
president is deeply unpopular.
And his only hope of getting
re-elected is by scaring people
and undermining the integrity
of the election itself.
And when he and his campaign
look back on their decision
to brag so much about this rally
in advance,
I bet they'll say
to themselves...
-I think I made a mistake.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As New York works hard to reopen
under phase two,
remember that we're still a city
in crisis.
And City Harvest
has been stepping up
to meet the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
we love you.